it's always the same desolate scenes
ghost towns destroyed soulless
this is because Ukraine is paying to
regain control of land that was occupied
by Russia
we are in visakopedia in the north of
Herson region they look on the faces of
those who stayed tell the story
here there is no sign of referendum
but the Russians are just five
kilometers away
and people there vote to decide if her
son should join the Russian Federation
the referendum is a sham according to
the Herson Administration now in Exile
we are getting information from local
people there you should understand it's
not a referendum it's a movie everything
is done for the cameras there was no
preparation according to the law they
are coming to people's houses with
weapons and forcing them they catch them
on the street Janna voted with her feet
by escaping to the Ukrainian side
she won't show her face because some of
her relatives are still in the Russian
held part of her son she's worried about
what could happen in the days to come
it's very difficult for us to speak to
people who are living in areas under
Russian occupation and from here it is
impossible to reach those areas so we
asked Andrew e if he could call his
mother who is still in her son and tell
us what is happening there
about 200 000 people have been displaced
by the war since it started seven months
ago Andrei is one of them
my father died three years ago but when
soldiers came to visit my mum they were
looking for her and my dad to vote there
were some people who voted for Russia
but not in big numbers
many others have fled regions where the
referendum has taken place over the past
five days
Mariana had stayed in russian-controlled
part of zaporija for seven months she
says being forced to vote was the last
straw
but for her sister vasilena this is a
Bittersweet moment
April you work with them you
lose to them and then all of a sudden
they embrace the colors of Russia and
they are happy and smiling that they are
part of Russia and while the
International Community has declared the
referendum illegal ukrainians fear that
the vote will mean even more war and
more Devastation before they regain
control of their country
in southern Ukraine